hello everyone so welcome to this really
much-anticipated and exciting event and
lecture with Donna Haraway our
distinguished visitor today I want to
introduce ourselves I'm in there Paula
gray well I'm the chair of women gender
and sexuality studies and I'm Joanna
Raiden and I'm a professor in history of
science and medicine the program for
history of science and medicine but
first before we begin we have many
thanks
our thanks to Gary Tomlinson the
director of the Whitney Humanities
Center to past director Rick Prum and
current director Priya Natarajan in the
Franke program for science and the
humanities and both these programs were
incredibly supportive and enthusiastic
about this event and made all this
happen with their eagerness and support
I also want to thank the Mandelbaum and
burns fund in LGBT studies for
supporting us WGS s program women gender
sexuality studies and the history of
science and medicine program the
department's of sociology and the
program in American Studies everybody
thank you so much for helping us put
this together
we especially want to thank our staff in
WG SS Maureen Gardner who was incredibly
her labor her labor her creativity and
her kindness just helped us so much and
made all this happen so incredibly
grateful to her as well as to our other
staff and to all the student helpers
with pitched in and supported us and
helped us and made this work so
beautifully to Alyssa for these great
buttons I hope you all got them and last
but not least to the Graduate School
here for recognizing Donna Haraway
extraordinary accomplishments with a
long overdue and deeply deserved Wilbur
cross medal for distinguished alum so
though many of you will recognize her
variously as the founder of cyborg
studies or feminist techno science
studies or a critic of primatology and
one of the most radically
interdisciplinary scholars of our time
it's important to remember that she
began her intellectual career as a
biologist here at Yale studying with
ecologist G evelyn hutchinson it was in
his lab where he encouraged his students
to read American pragmatist philosophers
like Whitehead and James that she began
to remake the history and philosophy of
science in fact her dissertation was
completed through what she calls an
interdisciplinary and between the
department's of biology philosophy and
history of science and medicine her
first book Christos fabrics and fields
metaphors of organism in
twentieth-century developmental biology
was based on her dissertation it was a
brilliant study of the epistemology and
ontology of life as considered through
the language used to describe it from
Yale Donna went on to hold positions at
the University of Hawaii and Johns
Hopkins before finding her true
intellectual home in the history of
consciousness program his
at the University of California Santa
Cruz where we have some distinguished
alums here also here she became
colleagues with Hayden white Jim
Clifford Angela Davis and Teresa de
Loretta's at Santa Cruz where she's now
professor emeritus she held the first
position in feminist theory in the
United States there she found her voice
within a few years she would produce
work that not only endures but continues
to inspire as we saw this morning at the
session on the cyborg manifesto
so the cyborg manifesto situated
knowledge --is the teddy bear patriarchy
these are among the most cited works
across the humanities and social
sciences and what bears emphasizing is
that they call into the question the
very idea of a humanities separate from
science her work explodes binaries
nature culture human machine science
humanities today as we reckon with the
aftermath of what is often called the
Anthropocene Donna Haraway continues to
lead the way encouraging us to find life
among the ruins to stay with the trouble
as my button says the title of her most
recent book those who've engaged with
this work know how deeply Donna
cherishes her non-human kin including
her late canine companion and research
associate cayenne pepper who inspired
another one of Donna's breakthrough
works when species meet in the
Associated companion species manifesto
yet we also want to know the many
generations of human companions and
research associates whom Donna has
trained and collaborated with these
collaborators and students have
contributed to the emergence of
disability studies STS and it's
feminists and dizziness and
multi-species guises women's gender and
sexuality studies animal studies post
human studies and more to read her work
is to join in a far-reaching community
of thinkers and makers who continually
offer much more than critique they
provide modes of beginning to repair the
damage at a moment when science and
truth feel
under attack Donna Haraway is work helps
us move away from easy binaries and the
temptation to surrender to a nostalgic
narrative of truth outside of politics
to be clear this is not about a retreat
from reality rather it's an embrace of
the mess the cthulhu seen as Donna has
urged us to think it the best science is
that which knows its past and is willing
to be accountable to its futures and
with that please join us in welcoming
the fabulous Donna Haraway
Wow I think as I said on other occasions
it's really only ones parents who should
be allowed to hear introductions oh I
remember when I joined the history of
consciousness which at that time was
often called his con I considered that I
was coming to do her scam I did my best
Jack I gave my inaugural lecture on
Galileo's the privilege and parabola and
circle and ellipses and so forth the
conic sections and did a sort of reading
of patriarchy through the DTO mess and
parabola and the gunsight the circle
over the the axes intersecting at the at
the site and so forth I did a whole
reading of war which was appropriate for
Galileo who among other things was
basically trying to calculate the path
of missile that would come in to the
Italian city-states of the time that he
was alive so that that kind of
combination of mathematics and and humor
and a kind of joining together with the
people to remember what we've inherited
so is to somehow be faithful to it has
has meant a great deal to me and it's in
that context that as a former graduate
student of Yale University I want to
remember some of what I inherited by
virtue of the privilege of going to this
place I got here because of the Cold War
of course when even Irish Catholic girls
brains became national resources highly
fundable so instead of a Catholic mother
of five to ten and a pro-life activist I
ended up doing her scam for life the I'm
remembering that the first person I t-84
at Yale University was named GE Pickford
whom I thought to be an elderly man in
the biology department who was waiting
for retirement and teaching the intro
biology courses and it was shocked as a
TA to find Jay Pickford constantly booed
and harass
and verbally assaulted by Yalies who at
that point did not include any women
women came to Yale in the middle of my
graduate school days there were a
thousand of us women graduate students
and way more staff women than that not
to mention the folks who cleaned the
buildings and the rest but women came to
Yale when Yalie undergraduates arrived
and the reason we knew that is they
hired a gynecologist
apparently unnecessary for those of us
who were not women not men really kind
of not so that I learned in the course
of teeing in that class that J Pickford
was grace Pickford and was a genderqueer
transvestite who had been married to my
dissertation adviser G Edelen Hutchinson
years before they had formed a companion
at marriage and had gone on a research
vessel from Cambridge to South Africa
because Grace was unable to go as a
single woman
so they married and went together and
had a kind of lifelong association at
Yale except that evylyn became very
famous founder of theoretical population
biology a really a massive presence in
his field as well as a reader of Italian
illuminated manuscripts we read of
course white Whitehead in purse and
James we also read Simone vial in Karen
Wolfe and Karen Stephens in his lab as
well as papers in theoretical population
ecology and molecular biology it was
really an extraordinary introduction to
an invitation to follow curiosity but
evylyn was well regarded and well
decorated whereas grace achieved full
professorship at retirement
having been adjunct most of the time
before because it was clear she would be
gone the level of sexism in the history
of Yale is no mystery to anybody and it
I give immense credit to my colleagues
of the people in this room the men and
women in this room who have addressed
this question in a range of really
important ways but like cleaning the
toilet it's never worked it's finished
it's not the whole house but cleaning up
the trouble remains necessary in every
generation
so I also because I've been mainly I've
been shaped by people like Kim tall
Barron Zoey Todd and many others I made
it a point to find out who the Native
American peoples in this particular area
of Connecticut are and were both are and
were the canoe kayak peoples account
member of the Algonquin Federation
largely theirs they though there is an
Algonquin Confederation of canopy act
tribal count of the compact tribal
council the actual descendants of the
people who lived in this region are
probably not the same probably not
directly to sit this isn't going to work
the people who are alive now were not
directly descended from the people who
were here before probably but various
members of the Algonquin Confederation
did inhabit this area as I think
probably most of you know I actually
found on the Yale New Haven website of
the support of the support website for
Native American students of organized
groups organized Native American
indigenous groups in this area include
over nine including the Golden Hill Park
assets the Mohicans the Narragansett of
Rhode Island the Wampanoag of Gay of gay
palm so forth and so on none of which I
assure you I knew when I was a graduate
student at Yale University
nor did I sort of knew about the history
of fishing about the history of the
slave trade certainly about the
histories of indentured servitude I
somewhat knew about the women in the
textile mills of New England I knew
something about the city on hill
traditions and I was an activist in
William Sloane coffin
civil rights movement of that period he
was an astonishing preacher and friend
of of Martin Luther King and yelled Yale
University students were organized
through the power of the word like you
can't believe I mean I was slumming my
way out of Catholicism going through
high church Protestantism to wherever it
is I landed namely I think in the earth
the lovers of the earth
the terran pagans if you will but while
i was slumming my way out of catholicism
at Battelle chapel William stone coffin
was a powerful presence in organizing
the people for justice so it's with
these kinds of memories that I begin
this talk that we are the granddaughters
of the witches you didn't burn and my
job is storytelling for earthly survival
we live on a damaged planet and it sings
term we need to be cultivating the arts
of living on a damaged planet for
ongoing flourishing and I take my sense
of time in this from Deborah bird Rose
an Australian who has worked her entire
working life in Australia you know us or
us American by birth but who has worked
with Aboriginal peoples from several
several different groups in Australia
and one of her teachers in particular
gave Deborah bird Rose an account of
time that she wrote into her dingo dingo
makes us human book and that has changed
my thinking forever namely said her
teacher a serious person a lawman in
English who is intent on taking care of
country the Anglo Australian version of
the Australian obligate of the
Australian series person's obligation in
life a serious person faces those who
came before does not face the future but
faces those who came before so as to
leave more quiet country to those who
will come after you don't face those who
come after you can't face those who come
after but we can face those who come
before and we can live in a thick
presence not an instantaneous presence a
thick now we're taking care of each
other human and non-human for partial
healing and for flourishing remain at
stake so it's that kind of temporality
that informs my theoretical methodology
if my theoretical and methodological
toolkit if you will which I have reduced
the signifier SF which obviously means
science fiction but fundamentally for me
it means cat's cradle or string figures
that kind of tying together and passing
on of patterns string figures science
facts I am
fiction slander fee self thank goodness
for the French speculative fabulous
speculative feminism and maybe above all
so far that kind of making patterns with
each other that are at stake to each
other patterns that can fail patterns
that can be dropped inherited patterns
invented patterns think we must said
Virginia Woolf in three guineas
she said it during World War one when
she was arguing against women supporting
the war effort in World War one a very
difficult position to take in that in
that time
Virginia Woolf think we must resonate
through the history of serious worldin
through the history of serious SF and
from Marilyn Strasser and I take these
kinds of slight of recursive not not a
joke it matters what stories tell
stories
it matters what thoughts think thoughts
it matters what world's world world's it
matters what relations relate relations
that the job for for those of us who
would be serious is to somehow inhabit
the troubled contact zones inhabit the
troubled patterning that is at stake and
not finished and undo and redo each
other compose and decompose in risk so
as to somehow strengthen the arts of
living on a damaged planet so as I was
as a descendant of sort of greekish
roots as a Western white woman in short
medusa is one of my one of my spirit
figures one of my patrons and medusa
have a thousands names the medusa not
the one that athena got on her shield
after a murder-for-hire
you know she hires Perseid to cut off
her head so she can put it on her shield
the the martinez murder-for-hire
basically told me who had borne of
Zeus's forever after the medusa whose
blood dripping from her neck Ava Hayward
teaches me this whose blood dripping
from her neck become the Gorgonio of the
western Mediterranean Medusa whose body
becomes
Pegasus and I tell you feminists have a
thing with horses I had a feminist
Theory seminar and Karin Kaplan's time
almost break hope breakup over the
question of horses it was an erotic
question Medusa the thousand names is a
spirit figure for this talk this mass is
actually tanned gooey duck skin there
are two universities in this country who
have mascots among the mollusks they're
the University of California with the
banana slug a fight we had with our
Chancellor which we won the banana slug
remained rather than the noble predator
sea lion and the other university in
this country that has a mollusk for a
mascot is evergreen University in
Olympia Washington where my godson just
graduated a couple years ago when I gave
a lecture and the kids who I was
lecturing to presented me with a gift to
die for which is a full mask they went
out to the you know to the shore and
they dug in the sand yay so deep and
pulled out this extraordinary mollusk
called a gooey duck GE OD uck okay which
is incredibly phallic they pull out this
gooey duck they skinned it tanned it and
made a mask which is my sense of really
understanding tentacular thinking and
kind of living living living in tentacle
arity and living living with the the
critters of the sea and the land and the
heirs for possible times for ongoing
times Phu Lewis from phonic it's not
from Lovecraft's Cthulhu
it's rather from the word phonic in and
of the earth the temporal T's in and of
the earth that are not simply ancient
but are all but are ongoing and are at
stake there are as at stake in the past
as they are in the times to come as they
are now the fool ooh scene is the kind
of temporality that I suggest we inhabit
as well as the capital of scene or the
Anthropocene or the plantation of scene
or other ways of naming temporalities of
urgency temporalities of grapes
of great consequence right now so that
the thylacine is a time i propose not to
replace all of the others but using
Marisol Delica danya's of phrase this
morning not only we are not only living
in the Anthropocene or the plantation of
seen or the capitalist scene or whatever
not only we are also at stake to each
other in the tentacular times of the
thylacine mast bite and gooey duck skin
okay so Toto IV paint actually carved in
paper and painted this amazing positive
and negative image of parting trees
which is the image I proposed for us for
the rest of my talk for thinking about
contact zones these this I don't have
anything to say about these these
extraordinary arboreal images except
that they they gripped me in their power
and in their their force away from each
other their force of parting but it's
also a force of being the same tree but
not the same tree a force of light and
dark night and day force of Moon and Sun
a way of thinking about story and
contact zones that grips my heart by the
way a biologist friend of mine who will
show up later in the lecture gave me
this image it's one of his favorite
images which he bought from Sottero
abbey a few years ago who lives in
Honolulu in my own ill-begotten and
he'll lived past I did contact zones
with cyborg world hangs you'll be
familiar possibly with these paintings
by lynn randolph my alliances with
artists have gone back a long way lynn
Randolph has been a painter she was
she's Texan is deeply in informed by the
retablo practices and in mexicana and
texarkana practice both of these are
obviously informed by the retablo
tradition and both of them are cyborg
figures that have appeared in my
previous work that foreground the
importance of narrative the the cyborg
there on your left was done
the time of Tiananmen Square and the
woman in question there her her parents
were Indian kahneman square when the
state moved against the demonstrators
the digitality of that of that
particular painting is impossible to
miss the animal spirit technology
historicity the real person the
cosmological astronomical figures in the
background it's that kind of implosion
of worlds which the cyborg world has
always been for me the other one
obviously works off of the barely
secularized Christian narrative of
techno science on a Salvation narrative
a cancer cure a narrative a narrative of
sacrifice and suffering an Eric a
narrative of surrogates the other is
usually sacrificed for the one so that
the the term sacrifice of course is what
is used for the killing of laboratory
animals and this particular mouse mouse
human female figure her breasts very
prominent is the first patented animal
in US patent law plants led the way and
we're patented actually decades before
which is very important to remember but
animals had a kind of honorary status up
until the 1980s when uncle Mouse is
patented so I go to my next artist who
is Patricia Peet Giannini also an
Australian artist a sculptor this is a
sculpture though it's also a gas filled
air bag that actually flies and it's on
it's I hesitate to say maiden flight
giving the degree to which those nipple
nipples are obviously so full of
lighter-than-air gas she's on her maiden
flight over Canberra commemorating of
all things Australian national day 100
years on the irony is abound okay she is
a whale she is flying over damaged land
and participe Giannini proposes her as
many things including a figure of wonder
a figure of evolution that might have
been a figure of what if she intended it
to be an it is an
actual flying you know an actual flying
airship that has about a hundred hours
of flight time left before it's
decommissioned so Yale would have the
money to get it to fly in New Haven
which I strongly recommend when Patricia
and I met we immediately began fabulet
in an ecology for the sky whale this is
the name of her she's a sky whale
because I thought that she was clearly
pregnant but that she was going to have
to come into the wetlands to give birth
but if she comes into the wetlands the
question of becoming airborne again is
going to be very difficult so her milk
must produce tremendous quantities of
gas in the calf as well as in herself
so we fab you laid the the kind of the
biochemistry of the milk and we we got
the kid drinking a lot of milk and
becoming more and more buoyant as the
gas and the kid built up and then mama
and baby flew and flew again and
rejoined a pod can you imagine a whole
pot of these things now were those who
wanted there were those who wanted this
particular piece of work banned for it's
pornographic tendencies I think they had
no sense of humor and frankly no sense
of wonder no sense of the speculative
fabulous that serious evolutionary
thinkers build into their way of waking
up in the morning so I go to another
contact zone we've left the sidewalk
realm
sky whale and Medusa of a thousands
names are figures protecting the rest of
this talk I hope and I go to the
circumpolar north and to the
controversies over hunting in particular
to the controversies over the ringed
seal not sick for the Inuit people of
the area and to the question of the the
tremendously vexed question and
importance of hunting and of foods from
the land from the sea for the peoples of
the circumpolar north in a context in
which they are living out the histories
of multiple colonialism's the histories
of commercialization of their animals
including a seal hunt and the histories
of animal rights opposition's of many
kinds
as you probably know the the dogs of the
Inuit peoples of Nunavut were
slaughtered by the Royal Canadian
Mounted Police not all that long ago in
an effort to force sedentary zation the
killing of the animals that are
important to the to indigenous people so
as to force senator ization is a very
old strategy and we'll meet it again in
this talk this particular ring seal this
particular not SiC was drawn by Paulette
Matic with Kevin O'Connor and the scan
drum after a summer Bush school study in
pongleton in Nunavut and it's an image
that I'm trying to develop the courage
to wear to an animal and advocacy
conference in Mexico City in January
I'll certainly show the slide whether I
wear the t-shirt now not I'm not sure
but you can see that sea ice tea is
being poured out into the liver into the
liver the lungs or the wake of the boat
a child is peering out of the tent
you've got the instruments of both
preparing the skin and of and of hunting
the animal and you've got where key sea
becomes seal and I propose this image as
a way of foregrounding a very
interesting contact zone that exists
right now that is at stake that we I
would propose need not and badly but
might end badly and it is in particular
it's the way of thinking about climate
change the Inuit people's who hunt
anoxic understand very well that the
molecules that this seal has eaten our
molecules circulate through their bodies
and that they are in the midst of global
global high organic organic chemical
pollution that that circulates through
the bodies particularly of northern
peoples really everyone on the planet
but northern peoples are not only the
subject of some of the most rapid ice
melting on the planet but also subject
to some of the most heavy pollution
burdens because of the concentration of
the food chain of the animals they
depend on for food now the sea there was
another excuse me my mind blanked which
I usually forbid it from doing
okay the anyway people are perfectly
aware of the change of the heirs of the
ISIS of the waters indeed they have an
elaborate and develop discourse they've
made films they have a TV they have a
whole TV station which you can find
several programs in relationship to the
change of the ice the change of
refractive indices in the atmosphere all
sorts of things which are collected wore
under a term called sila the breadth of
the breadth of the earth and the waters
and the airs the circulating breath of
the world under the the initiative term
sila which is different from climate
change but not against climate change
climate change is an important concept
that comes with southern scientists that
comes with a whole other array of
southern experts who have at best a
culturalist multiculturalist interest in
it enough to took language or an inuit
thinking or any no people and would not
consider that there are probably whole
practices of observation and
relationship to the changes in the ice
and the waters in the airs collected
under the under the under the
relationships of sila that climate
change apparatus is and their modelling
apparatuses are relatively blind to and
that a robust taking care of country in
the circumpolar north might might be
much better off with a kind of serious
undertaking to not translate and if to
took words into English or other Western
languages or vice versa but actually to
redo and undo each other so that nobody
comes out of the contact out of the
contact zone the same as the way they
entered it so that's the kind of contact
zone I we they long for and partially
construct it's the kind that's at stake
and it's absolutely at stake in hunting
rights of Inuit Inuit people's so I
return to my primary guides and my
notion of contact zones and I go to of
course dogs as my my god and like
handguns and I point out to them
repeatedly that the manual says right
here dog and handler form a team get it
we don't go off on our own I've got a
dog a dog has me we have each other who
are we and what is to be done okay well
these first dog who will enter this
story is Cayenne who was mentioned in
the introduction a purpose bread hi
Drive herding dog of the western United
States from the kind of dog that met the
Sheep imported from Australia to feed
the gold miners of the post-civil war US
conquest of California she belongs to a
lineage of white settler colonists of a
particular kind as I do too we bonded on
that basis as well as several other
bases the fact that she was a high drive
sports companion of mine and that we did
our damnedest in agility I'm wearing
that is one of our one of our insignia
one of our teams in our agility teams
was called an ARCA Aussies all the dogs
were Australian Shepherds and all the
women were named Maria in some form or
another including Madonna in my case the
Annika Aussies of course ran under Emma
Goldman's everybody's right to radiant
beautiful things under this Danish
anarchist banner for you know repurposed
for dog agility in California well that
counts as an aside that's not actually
part of the lecture that was an
indulgence but kind the fact that
Cayenne is a herding dog of sheep in
contrast territory got me curious about
sheep and it got me curious about the
shape of California and the Spanish
rough sheep got me curious about the
whole history of commercial pastoralism
as well as indigenous pastoralism got
curious about the way the DNA or the
Navajo adopted the shape of the Spanish
and turned them into the Spanish it into
okay turn them into a kind of shape that
was really critical to cosmological
performance continuous weaving to the
weaving of Navajo people
to the cosmological leaving that goes
into their rug work and there are other
weaving work that the Navajo churro
sheet became absolutely essential to the
practices of the Navajo on the Colorado
Plateau in DNA baqia the first slaughter
of churro shape in my story happens
under Kit Carson in 1863 as part of the
forced removal of the DNA into Bosque
Redondo and prison camps in New Mexico
for about four years and as conquerors
always do they slaughter the plants and
animals of the conquered peoples as
means of subduing them and removing them
from their means of subsistence and has
everything to do with what's going on on
see concealing in the circumpolar north
it has everything to do with the
preferential slaughter of the churro
sheep the cutting down of the peach
orchards are the cutting down of the
corn the removal of the DNA and then
their return after about four years with
the promise of restocking but very
little actual restocking nonetheless the
Navajo over a period of the next say 70
years acquired large flocks of sheep
cattle and horses and goats to the
extent that they were very much part of
a very severe erosion pattern on the
Colorado Plateau that led the
progressive new dealers under Roosevelt
to point out that carrying that they had
exceeded this thing called carrying
capacity these these were officials who
had absolutely no understanding of why
the Navajo kept so many animals for that
one needs to talk to Navajo go to the
archives of the Hubbell Trading Post
look to the work of Kathy McCluskey and
swept under the rug and dreaming of
she'd and Nash dimming of sheep and
Navajo country where you learn such
things as finished rugs of great quality
that sell for today on the art market
for hundreds of thousands of dollars
none of which goes back to the Navajo
we're sold as raw wool by weight in the
trading posts in exchange for sugar and
flour and other Trading Post items in us
in a system of Perpetual debt so that
having more and more sheep and weaving
more and more
and selling more and more rugs as wool
is very much built into a kind of forced
birth a kind of forced birth and death
that indeed I was very much part of
destroying the land destroying balance
destroying hosts row destroying right
relations of living with with and in the
land that Navajo elder not just elders
that Navajo learn as youngsters about
the principles of HUS row now I would
suggest that this is a story of a missed
contact zone that the biological concept
of carrying capacity is not a stupid
concept it has a dire history in all
sorts of contexts but not always but two
concepts of sustainability or carrying
capacity and the concepts of right
relations of the land could have been
brought into a serious conversation with
each other that confronted the
conditions of power of such a meeting
that the the officials of the of the
Roosevelt administration could have
asked what the Navajo knew about their
land they could have asked how mattre
focal pastoralism worked
they could have wondered how their
divvying up the land into rectilinear
plots and the distribution of grazing
rights by mid to male headed male headed
households forever after they didn't
have to do it that way it didn't have to
happen but it did and to this day
regulation of grazing permits in Navajo
territories is extremely contentious and
to this day the questions are it is
almost impossible to raise the question
of over grazing on because of this
horrible history which among other
things was a profound de capitalization
of the entire people the first D
capitalization the first wieldy the
first originally trauma in Toni
Morrison's term I am informed by kami
Chisholm another his congratu to the
first originally trauma was really the
removal under Kit Carson the second
originally trauma I suggest is the
massive D capitalization of an entire
people in the 1930s with with a murder
of their flocks there is a really
excellent book called waste landing
which looks at the history uranium
mining on these
the history of extraction that follows
these stories well this is not all a
story of doom and gloom you will not be
surprised to hear and I am I have been
there are many ways to tell a story of
building coalitions in this land and
they all involve a remarkable cast of
characters including kosher jerky the
American rare breeds Association the
genetic repository the span of farmers
of the area an anglo of agricultural
scientists from san luis obispo who
spent 40 years of his life running from
the law
trying to collect and build nucleus
flocks of Navajo sheep women and
resistance on Black Mesa who received
some of these sheep in the context of
the forced removals from from Black Mesa
the John McCain and his family who were
really who were behind many of the for
the forced removal legislation in two
waves on Black Mesa the building of an
alliance that shut down the Black Mesa
mine not after not until after it had
drained the aquifer unfortunately and
and shut down one of the major power
plants there are many stories to tell of
Alliance and partial healing in this
area that bring together peoples who
have decided not to be each other's
enemies but I want to just simply leave
an example of one that inspires me in
particular and it's the Black Mesa water
coalition and it's climate justice
program black mesa water coalition has
solar power just transition programs
food healing through food has all kinds
of programs on on Black Mesa this is an
organization that was started by young
people young students Hopi and Navajo
more more Navajo than hopi but both and
gijón Geron in particular was a Stanford
student who got her BS in environmental
sciences and he was one of several very
strong young young adults in the black
mesa water coalition I read we must
fight for everyone to have clean water
and clean lands we've been here before
we have been impacted we have been
imprisoned we have been pushed and
beaten
lives we want to live live with the
lives we want to live within our means
within the cycle of nature
this is climate justice refugees
migrants land based communities and
indigenous peoples same causes same
fight the the black mesa water coalition
was one of the groups that joined
together in phoenix a youth art project
to various community artists about three
or four other community groups to paint
this wall on the valley Youth Theatre in
downtown Phoenix which is the story of
the struggle on Black Mesa it's
difficult to see because it's it's so
big but you've got in a black mesa which
is you know big mountain a terribly
important that and a mother a very
important mother figure in the cosmology
of navajo geography you've got the
draining of the water for the golf
courses and the heavily as you probably
realized the the coal of black mesa has
been burned in the coal firing
coal-fired generating plants in order to
pump the Colorado River over the
mountains so that it can feed the desert
cities of the Southwest it's a trans
Basin water transfer world that we're
talking about here where the people from
whom the coal and the water are
extracted have neither energy have not
often are still to this day 2017 not
electrified or have access to clear
water clean water so that the the trans
Basin water transfer projects around the
world the one all in this lecture with
unless I have to end because of the
clock actually is in Michoacan and
relates to Mexico City another kind of
really important alliance in the story
that I'm trying to tell but you've got
this sweet you've got these the wind the
winter the Navajo Black Mesa water
coalition people have been building wind
projects in the Navajo Nation they've
been building solar projects they've
been developing indigenous food
practices to address some of the
diabetes issues so forth and so on and
they they were major players in the
Paris climate justice summit they are
really an impressive group of people
that gives me the sense that telling the
stories of destruction are terribly
important but telling only those stories
is a terrible mistake because the beings
of the land's heirs and waters are not
finished the human and the nonhuman
entities of this earth that still are
contesting for a vital fula scene are
still very much with us so that's my
first dog story kyon wrote that part
okay my second dog my second dog story
actually concerns my current dog who
came to join us about a year after kyon
died and turns out that she dropped out
of the sky from Taiwan and and totally
unexpected I was looking for a local dog
who needed a home and I wrote on my
internet you know I wrote on my
parameters for the pet finder search
thing I said within a hundred miles of
Santa Cruz resident I would drive and
meet the dog see if this was the dog was
to join our family and so on and Shinda
chu who was the dog who has her back to
you in that amazing calendar calligraphy
of play should achoo
turn up on the screen and I fell in love
instantly in the way you do with the
portraiture and the stories I mean
there's a whole apparatus of inducing
need and desire that goes on in the
adoption scene it's very powerful it was
really really interesting the way that
one is is induced is north into into
into love a really non-negotiable kind
so that the time that by the time I
learned that the office was in the East
Bay but the dog was in Taipei it was way
too late way too late
clearly she was hours and she flew in an
airplane with quite a lot of other dogs
and landed in California and I took her
name from an Ursula Le Guin novella
paradise is lost which is a
multi-generational spaceship story and
the Mandarin speakers of the first
generation by about the fourth
generation out Mandarin the Mandarin
term for where they're headed is shin
dat u so it means new earth
bad Mandarin and it seemed like the
right name for my little Taipei stray
dog
this next picture in front of you is is
Shinda chu and i trying to learn some of
the foundations of agility she has
focused to die for I mean when those
eyes are on you you do not let her down
she has her feet on an upside-down dog
bowl what she learns to do is put her
front feet on this bowl and then circle
around first that way and then that way
and then she does the same thing on the
Flexi disk and then she does the same
thing with her hind legs what she really
learns is where her body is
and this becomes a game and it's really
great fun but she is seriously paying
attention so she takes me to Taiwan and
I want to tell a contacts own story
there too and I want to first of all
show you a picture of dogs who are
actually not supposed to exist in the
world but do just about everywhere which
is healthy village dogs healthy free
roaming urban dogs dogs who are not
named starving
abused you know dying quickly who
require rescue instantly who must be
swept up into a rescue apparatus so on
so on I'm showing you there's these
streets of Taipei then pictures taken by
my friend Jim Clifford pictures that can
easily be taken by anyone who starts
looking but you could have also taken
pictures from immensely overcrowded
shelters from kill essentially kill
shelters you could have taken any number
of pictures also because the forced life
of the born ones affects not only the
human population you know seven and half
billion as I speak the forced life force
death of populations affects our
companion species as well as ourselves
and this is shin de Chu the day she was
picked up mm-hm
oh this is a dog who would not have made
it she's about five months old she was
clearly starving and she becomes part of
a research apparatus that is quite
amazing for its complexity the mainly
women and some allied men who run that
the fostering organization the
cup dogs in trouble including from the
kill shelters but they pick up adoptable
dogs because so-called adoptable dogs
are sure in short supply in North
America who could get plenty of
chihuahuas and pitbull pet dogs but
don't want them so they die in shelters
in large number while the mid-size cute
dogs like Shinda chew are picked up as
strays in Thailand and in Taiwan and in
various in Mexico in Puerto Rico and
marketed in North America as rescue dogs
they're picked up their foster they
become pets they also find homes in
Taiwan it's a really complicated story
you get one of these dogs you get a
whole community you got a website where
you tell each other stories you say
you've got a problem your dog is peeing
on your couch what should I do
get a new couch no you you are you will
have advice within 24 hours of
experience trainers and other people
with these dogs you get meetups once a
month in an off-leash dog park soon to
choose human and I met up with Moo me
her litter mate and her litter mates
humans who turn out to live in the Bay
Area also so Shinda Chu and her litter
mate meet up on a regular basis you get
an entire world in the rescue apparatus
and I propose this as a I actually care
about the born ones and the forced life
and forth for staff I care about the
what I'm calling the born and the
disappeared the immense numbers of
post-world War two forced life and force
death and I think the employment the
employment of dogs and humans with each
other is an important piece of this
complicated picture now the history of
the Formosan Mountain Dog she did she
was a kind of dog she's a mix she is a
so-called foremost mountain dog mix the
dogs of the Taiwan indigenous peoples of
Taiwan Aboriginal peoples of whom there
are currently speakers of about 16
different languages there were many more
before and many of these languages are
endangered the names of contemporary
taiwanese aboriginal groups are not
don't designate the kinds of groupings
in which they probably
lived in the 17th century but reflect
multiple layers of regulation and
displacement and resettlement and
renaming and so on and so on but
nonetheless our peoples who who have
accounts of their traditional ancestral
lands and certainly have accounts of
their languages and their families and
their genealogies and their life ways
and up until about the 17th century the
indigenous Taiwanese who are from the
archaeologists point of view an
Austronesian people the people who sweep
up from Southeast Asia and across Taiwan
and up into the southern part of
Melanesian and across and down all of
Polynesia the people those peoples are
the peoples who are related to the
Taiwan Aboriginal Taiwan indigenous
people and their dogs
these dogs swept across the same large
area it wasn't until the 17th century
that large numbers of settler colonists
arrived and of course they arrived from
China this is not a story of white
settler colonialism but it is a story of
settler colonialism the Taiwan has gone
through several waves of colonization in
several different kinds of intensity dot
Chinese Japanese Chiang kai-shek and the
Republic of China the contemporary
democratization of Taiwan is a really
interesting and complicated process
which among other things begins the
process of recognizing again and
Aboriginal indigenous rights to land
into not just to land but to practices
including the very vexed issue of
hunting the Japanese preferentially
killed are the Formosan the foremost
mountain dogs who are the hunting dogs
of the men and absolutely essential to
the subsistence practices for getting
food ok women it's same kind of complex
you're familiar with if you've read any
Melanesian anthropology or Polynesian
anthropology where there's that same
complex of animals and people are really
important to each other and the plants
are in there too Natasha but I'm I'm
sorry pigs dogs people for the moment
women are much more associated with
taking care of the pigs and the
and the killing and distributing of the
pigs the hunting of wild boar of the men
with their dogs is an was and is
important
the dogs were preferentially killed
several times just as the rough shape of
the Navajo a prevalent preferentially
killed several times they were
particularly subject to genocide under
the Japanese because of various
aboriginal groups are conducting
military resistance to Japanese
occupation by the end of World War two
and the effort to deprive them
relatively of access to food was very
important as well as just plain punitive
so very large numbers of the Formosan
mountain dogs were killed by the end of
World War two and then that the influx
of the consumer breed dogs as the
Republic of China Han Chinese large
settlement from the mainland become
relatively more secure economically
relative democratization the importing
of breeds from Europe and the United
States becomes a status act and many of
those dogs are then end up it's a status
act in a country that didn't have the
Associated practices of spay neuter and
The Associated many associated practices
so lots and lots of those stocks
interbred with the remaining foremost of
mountain dogs so the main genetic
contribution to the stray dog the free
roaming dog population of Taiwan is the
Formosan mountain dogs you can see them
everywhere but they they've mixed with
everybody who ever went to Taiwan of
large numbers of German shepherds for
example large numbers of Akitas the
Japanese war dogs made an important
genetic contribution to the dogs of
Taiwan you probably didn't come here to
learn about the genetics of the dogs of
Taiwan but nonetheless there you are
well just as the time with the so-called
pure Formosan mountain dog is really
scarce on the ground because of acts of
genocide I mean I mean it's not
surprising they become of course
precious symbols of primitive purity and
are collected by elite collectors of
dogs who go around to the mountains and
decide which dogs
that the the various villages might have
our so-called pure and collected as
breeding stock for a breed which is now
registered a registered closed stud
breed with a tiny little gene pool and
produced in figures like this now there
is one interesting difference in this
foundation dog of the main kennel that's
been doing this there are actually two
main kennels but this is one of them
she's a [ __ ] I don't think in North
America you would find the foundation
dog so prominently female in the most
important poster to advertise the kennel
I think the master of folk allottee of
this reconstruction of a national symbol
out of the murdered dogs of the
indigenous is quite interesting so I'll
just leave you with that but I want to
point out that these dogs have not
disappeared this is a picture taken in
the working dogs the this picture over
on your left was taken in 1900 in the
Japanese period and this is what those
dogs look like now I assure you if you
were able to see the individual dogs in
that meet up at the dog park the big
rescue social scene I showed you a
minute ago they look like they look like
that they look like those dogs the
morphology of these dogs and the
behavior of these dogs is doing well
thank you
the this is from 2010 and I apologize
for the fact that you can't see it so
you'll have to believe me when I tell
you that this is a contemporary Formosan
mountain dog the different group from
the the sassy ACK people over here the
seat people over here that these hunting
dogs are still very important parts of
the of living and mainly illegal hunting
by the indigenous peoples of Taiwan who
are under the contemporary
administration of Sai tsa I really
putting on a lot of pressure for the
recovery of indigenous rights they're
built into the contemporary constitution
in Taiwan and they are they are pushing
for the recognition of their rights
including hunting rights this was a
significant demonstration all over the
island in 2015 with both Han and
indigenous Ally
arguing this is these are rights that
are recognized under the Biological
Diversity Convention in the United
Nations these rights are recognized as
part of management of wildlife
simultaneously so-called Aboriginal food
is a big tourist item if you go to
Google and you start wondering what
you're going to eat when you're in
Taiwan you can go to any number of
so-called Aboriginal restaurants and eat
any number of roasted rats and other
very fine foods it the commercialization
the international tourist
commercialization of indigenous food is
a piece of this picture and will be a
piece is a piece of the problem of how
to conduct hunting in such a way as to
be part of right relations or what
Taiwanese people called Gaia the moral
universe the the kind of not our guy of
ayres the kind of relationships of
living in right becoming persons in
right relationship with with both human
and non-human entities also sorry I was
looking at this picture but you weren't
now you are there's the food okay and
here we have another entity who has sort
of left out of most of the indigenous
rights and other other discourses that I
pay attention to and that is to say that
the wild boars might actually have a
perspective which doesn't quite align
with this idiot hunters or with the with
the urban activists or with the feminist
anti-racist ally of whatever that the
one of the things that I have learned
from my animal advocacy colleagues is
that we we gloss rather quickly over the
question of plants and animals and
microbes who are for that for each other
and not necessarily for us for the that
the symbiote genesis of this planet is
not human o centric that we're part of
the picture but not always we're not
part of every picture and that the
question of the hunting of a species
like this is a very serious
one which I think needs to include not
just the indigenous hunters and their
allies of whom my number myself but also
the people who are seriously worried
about the indigenous wild boar by the
way it's the same species that destroys
California incredibly destructive
species out of place but in place is
something else again these particular
animals that you see on your screen are
in a zoo I know you thought that they
were wild so I didn't tell you who they
were in a zoo until the end
the indigenous demonstrations for being
on the Commission's that determine which
land should be should be indigenous
lands so far
indigenous members of those Commission's
have been very scarce and the amount of
land which has been returned in title
under the current administration while
not nothing is a small fraction of
probably what it needs to be for any
kind of reckoning and kind of healing
from the multiple layers of it of
oppression for lack of a better word
okay so I end with fiction I end with
art and I look to the novel of the man
with the compound eyes which if you
haven't read you must run immediately to
read this is again something Shinda Chu
made me read she's made me curious about
all things Taiwanese including that
taiwan taiwanese fiction translated into
english because I can't read Mandarin or
any other Chinese language this one
involves a young man sent off from his
people of a Pacific island the second
son is sent out to sea never to return
the the people is very well very well
developed in the fictional presentation
in the novel he ends up running into a
Pacific trash vortex which is swirling
around and crashes into the east coast
of Taiwan which in the other parts of
the novel has been having this developed
developed plot which involves two
different indigenous Taiwanese groups
and a whole complex array of ethnically
diverse Chinese actors and to foremost
Sand Mountain Dogs which endeared the
book to me forever
the point of the novel is a kind of near
future speculative fabulet of
environmental catastrophe that that can
environmental catastrophe that can also
be kind of part of a partial resurgence
of living well on the land and the sea
with each other it's a it's a really
fascinating speculative fabulous set in
Taiwan most of the speculative fabulous
an environmental fiction that I know are
set elsewhere it's a Pacific story as
really the ring seal story and the story
that I will end my lecture with which is
becoming worldly with Pacific island
tree snails my last contact zone these
are a Canton Ellis species the Pacific
Island tree snails in Hawaii used to
number probably about three or four
hundred species they're down to well
fewer than a dozen all of them are
endangered
they have been wiped out through
multiple insults beginning with such
things as the cutting down of sandalwood
trees for the China trade the cutting
down of the forests were shipping the
leveling of forests for plantation
agriculture the introduction both
deliberate and nondeliberative predators
including including three different
species of rats including a predatory
snail is it that was introduced to
control paths but ended up not liking
what it was supposed to eat and really
liking to eat the Pacific Island tree
snails tourists collectors the children
of missionaries who collected these
unbelievably gorgeous shells are the
collections around the world in museums
tell you something about the other
predator which is homo sapiens a direct
predator not just destroyer of habitat
well my friend who I promised to bring
back into the story Michael Hadfield who
is a marine biologist ecological
evolutionary development developmental
biology he's one of the people who is
studying how bacterial products cue the
settlement of organisms onto coral reefs
he's been very interested in fouling
organisms and and bacterial films and
how the free-swimming larvae are queued
too not only is it time to settle down
but we have a
for you the ways that critters a really
widely different taxa require each other
in order to do their lives he's been one
of the players in ecological
evolutionary developmental biology and
the tradition of lynn margulis but in
his copious free time he has been a
bulwark he has been a fierce man for the
Pacific Island tree snails and their
lands and their peoples and I have
simply followed his slime trail okay on
Michael and his colleagues beginning in
the 1970s conducted multiple surveys on
Molokai II doing capture and release of
the tree snails making tiny little marks
on them when putting them back really
gently and then showing up the next year
and doing the same thing
finding out that these are snails that
have to be four or five years old before
they reproduce maybe only maybe make one
or two babies a year and that each tree
has its own specific snails and you can
have speciation on Ohio day who a tree
over here and over here and over here
might have widely different snails
that's like Island biogeography on Ohio
Lihua trees Michael did the basic
biology he used that basic biology to
file the first Endangered Species Act
form to try to block a highway on Oahu
that was to join to mate to major
military installations h3 on Oahu they
failed to block the highway but they did
get the Endangered Species Act
designation for Pacific Island tree
snails which Michael and his colleagues
have used with genius ever since to get
in the way of military free-fire zones
to block to get in the way of further
destruction and to build alliance with
Pacific Island biologists and and
geographers and students that to somehow
do a kind of partial healing the picture
over here which is Makua Valley on Oahu
those scars that you see on these on
these mountains those actually aren't
the scars of logging they're really the
scars set by fires from military bombing
practice over a period of about 65 years
this area of
who was used for military bombing
practice set lots of fires so what
you're really seeing are is military
wounds one of the things that Michael
and his colleagues have had to do is
take much conservation biology take
remaining Pacific island tree snails of
various populations into the lab and
produce conditions for them such that
they can reproduce such that they have a
chance of being reintroduced to
appropriate habitats should that habitat
be restored or continue to exist so what
you see I've got very interested in the
material semiotics and the materialism
of actually caring okay but what it
actually takes take you know collecting
or here like who leaves every couple of
weeks and making sure they got the right
kind of black fungus on them learning to
culture that black fungus on agar so
that you can feed your snails keeping
the temperature just so watching the
snails die because a lab manager takes
over who forgets to check the
temperature over a weekend and you lose
most of your populations the kind of
ongoing loving and mourning and caring
and working that goes into trying to
make a difference the fences that are
built to keep out predators are
incredibly ingenious they built
exclosures not enclosures the X closures
you dig down four feet into the ground
and you put in corrugated corrugated
metal and you have an overhang over here
where you can put in little little salt
traps or some but you know snails who
are going to climb up the predatory
snail who might climb up the fence and
then fall into the salt bath and die and
you've got a little zapper little zapper
electric wires run by little solar
panels on the other side of the fence on
a neighboring tree and you've got barbed
wire over the top to keep out human
hikers so you have a kind of multiple
predator exclusion and the biologists
have this kind of a frame that they put
over the fence periodically so that they
can get up and down and study the
populations and see how they're doing
and then it up and down and then hide
their a-frame and make sure the fences
are still intact that's what it takes to
allow small populations to make it so
when Tom van
and asks you know what is it like to
live on the on the ledge of extinction
extinction is a process not an event
what does it take to hold open space for
another and what's going on in holding
open this space well Michael and his
colleagues have hardly given up they
think that there will be further losses
they're not particularly optimistic but
they think it matters they think they
can make a difference they think they
have made a difference there's several
ways in which that's true
so POG an island in the Northern Mariana
Islands after Fukushima the slimy
authorities in Saipan and the slimy
authorities in Tokyo make arrangements
to dump low so-called low-grade nuclear
waste on POG an island and mine the
pozzolan mine the the volcanic ash for
agricultural use in Japan so you bring
in the ships laden with radioactive
waste and you leave with ships laden
with volcanic ash and it's a win-win
deal and all you have to do is dredge
the harbour and bomb yeah and and you
know turn the island into a nuclear
waste dump Michael and his colleagues
stopped it they generated a safe hagen
Island that went viral
internationally very quickly they allied
with tomorrow families in the Northern
Mariana Islands who still trace their
ancestry to the island whose
grandparents had ranched on the island
before a massive eruption caused
evacuation a few decades ago but
families who have plans to move back to
pokken Island that whether they move
back only for day visits or move back to
live is less the point then that this is
land that is still very much in their
storying of who they are in the world
my colonias biological colleagues form
alliances with these these are the bio
geopolitical activists over here on POG
an island well they stopped the
low-grade nuclear waste and then three
years later in the context of the turn
the pivots the pacific of the obama
administration POG an island and Tinian
Island are designated as a new free fire
zone for the US Marines so that they
would simply become target practice on
both islands but they hit a hornet's
nest because the biology
and the families and the international
activists were ready to move and are
still moving and I find it inspiring
that people these are people who really
put themselves in the way of projects
and win at least sometimes I also am
very proud of Michael and his colleagues
for their internship program at the
University of Hawaii on the Manoa campus
that has now for about three decades
brought Pacific island kids from the
various islands for interning and I have
watched the picking kids up at airports
the staying with them when their
grandmother dies in Palau and you can't
get home and then and not getting home
for that is a very big deal the the kind
of ongoing mentoring the ongoing
mentoring of folks into early
professional life and numerous dozens of
this of the graduates of this program
work as environmental environmental
biologists and environmental
policymakers and educators in the
various islands of the sea of islands of
the Pacific now Michael comes from a
tradition of marine biology stations
which is all of you know our major
colonizing institutions the marine
biology stations of the Pacific were a
major arm of the colonial apparatus in
the Pacific but not only again that
these these marine stations also are our
precious precious places of the
cultivation of the capacities to care of
the kind of caring that builds those
exclosures the kinds of caring's that
connect with it so that the Chamorro
families and the scientists can connect
with each other
so you've got Michael who begins his
biological career 45 or so years ago as
a so-called pure scientist studying the
vermut ed mollusks off the course of
California in the Stanford marine labs
in in Hopkins marine labs of Stanford
University a pure biologist who had no
idea that politics mixed with science
who now thinks of the bio geopolitics of
his science as internal to the work it's
not just something you add on in order
to keep your snails alive he understands
that
you're gonna understand the habitats of
these human and non-human players the
technological the human the other plants
and animals the microbes the people that
the bio geopolitics of science is what
has to be practiced you this is a very
he's hardly a conventional person but
this is not a radical in the beginning
this is a radical now it's not just that
his wife is an activist with the
revolutionary communist party which we
won't go into their other parts of this
story but the part that I want to tell
is that this is a person who by taking
taking the the being you know you have a
snail a snail has you
well the snail has Michael and it's not
optional and it's life changing
and it causes a whole set of rethinking
of what constitutes a contact zone and
what context living what constitutes
living and dying with each other well on
this planet and I end with the image of
the mariposa we're coming up to a dia de
los muertos the time when the
butterflies of the Great Eastern Flyway
are returning to the fur and oak trees
of Michoacan and settling in these very
few small groves that still exists for
the overwintering overwintering
butterflies of the eastern Flyway and
from the point of view of the Missoula
and other both mestizo and in India
peoples of this area of Michoacan the
returning butterflies are the returning
ancestors who come back on el Dia de los
Muertos in a kind of sim anima genesis
so I closed my story of symbiogenesis
with an opening up to something else of
semana my Genesis with Mariposa and
Michoacan thank you
it's a great mask sorry for the time
problem but thank you so much so what we
want to do is try something a little
experiment we want to ask you to spend
just a minute to turn to your neighbor
and talk about what you've heard and
then we're gonna open things up to
questions and invite you to come up to
the mics on either side to ask questions
in the time that remains okay so just a
minute
very lively I'm sorry I went over time
the stories just keep coming if I had
not added extra stories I would have
been able to
okay okay guys wow that's amazing um I
think we have a person at the microphone
who wants to speak okay we're gonna
start with the questions now thank you
thank you for all those wonderful
stories I was attracted to the lecture
by your interest in species and what I'm
wondering is if we make an analogy
between the idea of species and the idea
is that sustained other kinds of
destruction such as race such as gender
such as orientation and all of those
have been dealin amazed at least we hope
so and they've all been converted from
qualitative to quantitative from binary
to multifarious manifold could the same
thing happen with species could we could
we demolish the idea of qualitative
designations for species that authorized
us to kill and exploit others in the
ways that we've done with those other
classifications very much so and the the
kind of unpacking of these category of
these unitary categories has been
ongoing most certainly for species to I
would tend not to use words like
demolish and and so forth it has it kind
of throwing the baby away with the
bathwater edge to it now if you actually
feel the same way about race and gender
and and the rest I think that what we
are getting better at is under these
understanding these things as
positionings and processes and and
fixings understanding them as jaren's
rather than nouns and the the the
history
most biologists understand that what
constitutes a species is always an open
question they've understood this for a
long time and at the edges species
species identities have been understood
to be highly permeable from the get-go I
think that the whole concept of species
has been undergoing a lot of a lot of
change to do without it I think is a bad
idea I think rather opening up opening
it up to its its perceptual quality and
it's really it's relationality there's a
kind of relentless insistence on not not
the vowed relation as a noun but relay
teams are the smallest units of analysis
and that there is no such thing as a
species by itself any more than there is
such a thing as a person by itself that
these are relating x' and co
constituting x' in various kinds of ways
and that the job is to inhabit and and
be and come to be accountable to and
with these relating x' yeah so in in the
cyborg manifesto you spoke about
coalitions of affinity of being as you
phrase it related not by blood but by
choice and in what a- witness you wrote
that and i'm sick to death and here on
quoting of bonding through kinship and
the family and you long for other models
of solidarity and human unity and
difference and yet in saying with the
trouble and in the title of your talk
the the metaphor that you provide for
relating and becoming with with humans
and non-human others is kingships about
the politics of those terms so versus
solidarity versus affinity and if you
find me throughout this whole period
grappling with what kinds of collective
nouns to use for a really strong and
enduring and non optional and you know
can move through the generations and all
of them share a common effort to demote
biogenetic relating as the fundamental
way of forming to whom you belong and
from whom from whom you come and to whom
you are accountable
that the the questions the making of kin
the making of kith and kin it's not that
it's not genealogical - but again I'm
using Marisol sprays it's not only and
oftentimes it just plain isn't that the
making of kin who are who you know I
have
well here's Marilyn's strat there in one
day saying look the word relations was
only in logic until into the 19th
century in British English it became a
tent a term for my cousin sitting in the
living room I didn't even know I had who
now says I have to pay for his
daughter's marriage you know somewhere
in the 19th century that a relation
became that the person who can make
claims on you
and to whom you are accountable who you
can't just shed that's the relation as a
kin term is a very is very late which i
think is really fascinating so I'm
looking for ways of configuring our our
cultivation of the capacities to be able
to respond to each other over with the
durational quality to it
and there is no one way to do this and
different peoples subject to different
histories are going to be asserting
relatedness in various ways but I think
of the ways that Kim tall bear and
others many others have been arguing
against DNA as a the marker of tribal
belonging have also been arguing about
what constitutes membership and
membership constitutes being is
constituted by being recognized by a
community as one of its members that's
one very strong part of the argument but
yes it matters if you're someone's
daughter or son or whatever so how - I'm
not against I for one thing I have a bio
I have bio kin I feel very strongly
about I also understand that these bio
can are constituted in two families in
in histories of heteronormative
patriarchal family relating and so on
and so on you know it's it's both and so
I'm not I and recently I've hit upon the
term odd kin as my favorite term but
it's mobile
or incoherent
[Laughter]
so I have a question regarding working
within conservation
when stakeholders are both indigenous
peoples and people inheriting the long
large legacies of colonial science to
what extent must these healings always
be partial in which land is not
necessarily being recognized as
belonging to a group or continues to
remain under the jurisdiction of former
colonial partners or it's actually
that's not actually what I tend to mean
I don't mean what I use the word partial
it's not that that I'm referring to
impartial healing I think that the wait
you're probably thinking of the
complexity of the many co-management
agreements
Canada is full of them the United States
has fewer but has them to operating
under regimes of both state provincial
federal and private property and tribe
and tribal property many property
regimes and sovereignty disputes as to
whose law takes precedence where I think
there's no general answer to the
question you're raising but I think that
the question one of the questions which
is almost never raised in the context of
the United States but needs to be part
of this mix is restr 8 it is reparations
and that ending and including a return
of title the politics of that are
obviously very complicated and would
potentially be very violent the
occupation of the Malheur Wildlife
Refuge of last winter is a very
interesting example of where the the
wildlife managers and the the people
who's the owners of land that are the
initiatives peoples of the area we're in
agreement over and against the occupiers
who were who were claiming to represent
indigenous people in their occupation
but were quickly disavowed the
potentially the
this struggle for for who belongs where
under what conditions including who
needs to get research permission from
whom in order to study what who owns
knowledge who owns stories there are
stories that anthropologists know for
example that they don't feel authorized
to tell because they don't own the
stories the family who told them the
story owns the story my own I mean
controls rights rights of access I'm
thinking of ownership as a bundle of
rights of access and the also I'm
thinking that because we are currently
living not just in a intensely layered
and complicated set of histories all at
the same time and struggling with each
other with an attempt to do it
to maximize transitional justice and
nonviolent and peace to okay and we're
living with damaged lands what I'm
talking about when I talk about partial
healing I'm often trying to signal with
a very short hand that there's no status
quo ante there is no even if even if
people could agree on what they wanted
to restore which is not going to happen
because restoration is also a question
of desire and imagination and fabula and
and storytelling and inhabiting but the
there will be you know those and those
those Hawaiian tarot farms are at the
bottom of the mountain that was the free
fire zone are not coming back the there
I think that that the necessity of
partial healing the necessity of
recognizing that there has been
irreversible loss and there will be yet
more irreversible loss and that living
in loss is one of the things that
serious people need to learn how to do
without either cynicism or despair or
some kind of lurch to a techno fix or
some kind of lurch to denial
that that's why the the image of staying
with the trouble occupies me so much
these days that much can be done to make
this a more flourish in place for the
mortal critters of Earth a huge amount
can be done to make the earth a place of
flourishing living and dying for its
multiple critters including its non
living entities you know not blowing up
another mountaintop to get at its coal
for example even if it didn't kill
everybody in sight the the much can be
done and much is being done but I think
it's terribly important not to have some
kind of fantasy of holistic healing well
I think it defeats us before we start
and I think it's a bad it just is a
desire that isn't serious to me thanks
for the talk and I have to sort of ask a
sort of embarrassingly naive question
potentially but one that I couldn't help
thinking about and that's how you're
thinking about contact zones showcases
both the salience and the limitations of
the traditional animal liberation
movement which focused so much on
vegetarianism and related forms of like
small-scale activism I I guess and it
seems like really you you sort of
pointed some really interesting examples
that might introduce some new and
difficult contradictions into that kind
of position I think I'm you know namely
what would it mean for instance in the
context of the United States with its
sort of factory farming system to be a
vegetarian yet to support indigenous
rights hunting elsewhere so I I think
that that's probably a question you
think about contact zones would have a
lot to say about and I asked it just as
it's not an IU question it's really a
different question um it's a very
difficult question and one of the things
I've learned over a period of years of
doing doing this work is that my
beginning image of what constituted
animal rights of who were animal rights
people was it was often just plain wrong
that I had almost no idea who the people
really were and what they were really
doing and what their organizations were
I
had certain kinds of examples and
anecdotes and so forth and so forth but
I have come to have a much more robust
I think sense of the complexity the
animal rights an animal advocacy scene
and the society Society for let's see
Institute for animals society and
animals is a the Institute for society
and animals is a really good place to
look for some of the complexity the
probably most folks in those
organizations are very clear about
opposition to factory factory farming
and conditions of living and dying for
both humans and nonhumans in factory
farming conditions most of those folks
are terribly worried about the hyper
commercialization of the pet trade they
are very concerned with the the the
meat-eating as a wealth state as a
symbol of wealth and status the global
increase in meat-eating which results in
the forced birthing of billions of
chickens every year for the sole purpose
of slaughtering them epidemic friendly
whirlings there's there's relatively
little controversy and some awfully good
analysis and quite a lot of action in
animal advocacy organizations around
that whole apparatus of raising other
animals as a as a mode of extraction
really extraction of their lives for
flesh there is much less agreement or or
shared vision around questions of
indigenous hunting becoming seal with
seal for example which is just one
example there is a sense that this is
this is an important place to be engaged
in contestation in cooperate in conflict
and collaboration with Angela Davis's
constant image in conflict and
collaboration many of the vegans I know
are vegans as a form of witness in the
context of a society in which
meat-eating is as normative as
patriarchy oh actually more so
patriarchy is action
not well-regarded in many places where
meat eating is avidly you know eating
eating animals raised in in pain and
suffering avoiding factory raised meat
is really difficult when you're
traveling all sorts of other things any
case many of the vegans I know
understand the contradictions of their
own situation including wearing leather
shoes for example or all sorts of thing
I am finding in the animal advocacy
community part of which is an animal
rights community but not all not all are
happy with the discourse of rights for
many of the same reasons that other
political people aren't happy with the
discourse of rights but they'll use it
selectively I am finding this to be a
robust complicated group of people I
know animal rights advocates and new
zealand's who were involved from the
get-go with housing housing issues you
know civil rights issues so on and so
forth and so I've lost my knee-jerk
reaction myself to characterizing animal
rights people and I find the issues that
they're raising can't be done away with
that it's question of killing and eating
other sentient critters is not going
away anytime soon and that doesn't mean
that it's that it's oh I think some for
example I've said this would be the last
thing I'll say I am NOT a pro-life
person that was a hard position to reach
I'm not a pro-life person in
reproductive politics I think is
sometimes it's important to kill
I don't think abortion is not killing
okay I but I think sometimes it is the
the more I'm a really important thing to
do and that the the place where that
decision has to rest is with the
pregnant person okay so in that since
I'm not a pro-life person but I also
refuse to forget that that there is loss
and and just Frank and killing involved
in the act including if I affirm and I
mean who cares what I think I can be a
good thing to do not just a necessary
thing to do but even a good thing to do
well I think the killing of other and
comes under the same set of concerns
killing and eating other animals as food
is all over the world and not just in
the indigenous world a part of
maintaining ways of life that I am NOT
interested in seeing become nothing but
museum specimens the restoration of
grasslands pastoralism for example the
kinds of farming of animals that goes on
in medium scale not all smalls not all
super small-scale the efforts to develop
various kinds of slaughter processes
that are more attentive to the
experience of the animals I am part of a
movement that is committed to living and
dying birthing and killing and against a
pro-life purity position and that puts
me both at odds with and in alliance
with my animal advocacy colleagues
[Music]